Zanna, what is happening in beauty?
So much is happening in beauty.
Okay, so Vogue posted a tribute
to Princess Diana's beauty obsession,
electric blue eyeliner.
This is one of the best makeup moves
we should all be trying right now at home,
especially after watching your interview with The Crown.
Make sure you check out this article online
it's really good and it's all about the waterline,
popping the water line.
Yes and I actually have Ostro on our website,
an NYX color that I really loved,
it's very hard to find this particular blue,
but I love blue, blue is back.
Blue is back.
New trend.
And that one is very affordable, the NYX one.
Yes.
it's great.
And you are gonna suggest one from Sephora.
Sephora's is great too,
glides on $7, you can't go wrong.
Okay, perfect, that'll be on our website.
Okay, Forbes reports that French Royal Jelly,
a European facial treatment from bees
is finally launching in the states here in America,
buzz, buzz.
But by the way,
Royal Jelly also has these incredible properties
and it's from a queen bee
and Milk Makeup your company is vegan
and honey is not vegan.
Honey is not vegan
and we don't use beeswax either in our mascara,
we use a different binding agent
which is hemp derived cannabis seed oil.
Yes, in fact, there's,
you are one of the first people to come to the market
with CBD makeup.
Yeah.
And it was a huge--
And we're very proud of it.
Phenomenon.
Yeah, we love our, being the first insight zeitgeists
in ingredients so--
Yes.
No, I'm the biggest Milk Makeup fan
Okay, Zanna your story.
Okay, also making headlines
is Revolution Beauty's Friends, 2.0 collection.
I know you're gonna love this one, Drew.
These are shades, lip glosses, body scrubs,
based on the looks of the iconic show.
So we're talking lit glosses named Chandler, Joey, Ross.
We've got a, I mean there's so--
You've got the like iconic door,
Door.
like peep hole palette, everybody does pallettes now.
Pallettes are all the rage.
Pallettes are all the rage,
but they also have a Central Perk coffee cup,
which is reusable and it's got a scrub in it as well.
That one I do want.
Oh, I love a good scrub.
Okay and finally, beauty guide or excuse me,
Guide Beauty has created easy to use makeup tools
with people, okay excuse me,
I'm messing this up.
This is Guide Beauty
and these are easy to use makeup tools
with universal design for people with disability
like ALS or arthritis and their packaging is phenomenal
It's gorgeous.
And it is such an impressive brand.
So impressive and you know what?
This is radically easy to use
and what beauty company doesn't want to be
radically easy to use anyway.
this is great for everybody with disabilities or without.
I have to say
It's beautiful.
this is probably gonna be my favorite beauty story
that we do all week and I didn't know about them
and I'm so happy to promote them.
They'll be on our website as well.
So you can take a look and get to know more about this
beautifully packaged, highly functional,
extremely thoughtful,
one, one to market that has really got everybody's backs.
I'm obsessed, Guide Beauty.
Guide Beauty guys.
Okay and that was a Speedy Drew's News.
Thank you Zanna.
(upbeat music)